hi I'm Carmen Berlin I'm the author of
let's take this offline it is a book on
service workers it'll teach you
everything you need to know and more
about service workers and making your
web app work in an offline setting it's
really important these days now that
everything is so reliant on the Internet
to provide a fail-safe for people who
lose their internet connection for
whatever reason it could be commuting to
work traveling being in a remote area it
could be a lot of different reasons that
the internet goes out and a service
worker goes a really long way toward
providing a really consistent experience
in your web app so today what we're
gonna do is we're gonna learn how to
write a very first service worker now
before we get started writing service
workers I think it's really important to
think about what happens if you have a
site that doesn't have a service worker
so this particular site is really really
popular unfortunately it doesn't have a
service worker so if we right-click and
go into our inspector and dev tools you
can actually see under application a
list of service workers that a site has
this particular site doesn't have any so
if it were to go offline as you saw
before there's not a lot that is helping
a user out at that point it's a really
unfortunate user experience for somebody
who for whatever reason you know maybe
they're traveling maybe they're in a
remote area again they can't access it
because there are connections in and out
it happens everybody so it's really
important to provide that consistent
experience so over here we have a site
that's actually already offline and as
you can see it's still loaded in and if
you click over into network
and click on one of these requests you
can actually see that this is loading in
from the serviceworker so if we refresh
from serviceworker no problem let's jump
into so code this is our very simple
very first serviceworker so let's step
through it you can see that there are
three functions we've got our on install
our activate and then fetch so this is
derived from the serviceworker life
cycle the life cycle goes in this order
first the browser sees that there is a
serviceworker that needs to be installed
it'll trigger that on install event
this function will handle for it next
the serviceworker will be activated
lastly it'll handle for fetches and in
between times when none of those events
are being triggered then the
serviceworker is idle a couple of quick
things you need to know about a
serviceworker before we get started a
serviceworker has to run over HTTP it
has to have an ssl certificate you can
get an SSL certificate there's services
out there that provide these let's
encrypt is a really great one definitely
recommend doing that this is really
important for production if you're just
messing around trying to get a feel for
service workers there is an exception so
you can run on local hosts you can run a
service worker on localhost and you
don't have to have an SSL certificate
that's really great again if you're just
getting started and you just want to
write some to kind of get a feel for
them keep in mind that that has to be a
local host you can't run from your
filesystem you can't run from an IP
address it has to be a local host so if
you're seeing errors that seem strange
to you that is a good thing to check
so let's look at this code a little bit
closer this install event is what gets
triggered first the browser is going to
see that a service worker is registered
and then trigger this event within this
event we're calling this caches dot open
function that accepts a string parameter
which is going to be the name of the
cache if the cache already exists it'll
go ahead and open it and you can then
access anything within it if it doesn't
exist it'll create it for you that
returns a promise which is our next
function that promise resolves with a
reference to the cache we just opened
within that we're using this add all
function that accepts a array of strings
which are relative paths to files within
this application there's another way you
could do this called cached ad and it
looks like this it's very very similar
the main difference is it only accepts a
single parameter and so you might not
want to use it if you've got a lot of
files that you need to add personally I
generally use at all underneath that
since it's our first Service Worker we
want to go ahead and just let ourselves
know that everything cached successfully
while at all does return a promise it
doesn't resolve with anything so this
isn't really necessary to our
serviceworker it's just something for us
to know that this worked another thing
that I really recommend adding is this
cache method so it can be very difficult
to debug a serviceworker and it's just
really nice for you to know while you're
working on them but this is what went
wrong if something went wrong and this
is what it is so I highly highly
recommend including those
next in the lifecycle is activate so
activate happens right after our install
event is finished you can do a lot with
in and activate event but since it's our
very first one all we're going to do
right now is let ourselves know that our
service worker is successfully activated
and it's ready to go
the last method that we're going to add
to our service worker today is this
fetch method and this is where we're
actually handling for those fetches that
occur within an app so you might have
expected a return statement here but
it's actually really important to use
this event dot respond with method
instead if it not respond with is what
allows you to actually send a custom
response or an on network response
basically back to the fetch request if
you were to return that would never make
it back to your fetch request and that
fetch would actually go ahead and go
over the network which is obviously not
what we want because we're working on a
Service Worker so this particular
function accepts a function parameter we
passing Cash's match so the first thing
we need to do is see if we even have a
matching response to the request
that's what caches stop matches doing it
returns a promise and you're seeing that
right here and you might notice that we
have this response wrapped in an if
block and so that's because if you look
for a request that doesn't have a
matching response that's going to return
undefined so it's really important that
you always wrap that in an if block so
if it is defined we'll go ahead and
return that response and then we want
that else because if it is not defined
we definitely want the user to still get
the data so this is our very first fully
functioning Service Worker there's just
one more thing we need to do
I mentioned that the browser will
register our serviceworker
or it'll see that it needs to be
registered and we're doing that over in
our index dot HTML it's just this tiny
little if block right here so we call
this method navigator dot serviceworker
dot register and then we pass in the
relative path to the serviceworker
generally service workers are gonna live
at the root level of an app and the
other thing I wanted to point out to you
is that navigator dot serviceworker is
while service workers are really widely
supported there are definitely legacy
apps out there that are so running on IE
11 and maybe even earlier versions where
service workers are not supported so
there's really no loss in wrapping
something in an if block like this and
using feature detection I highly highly
highly recommend it and that is it
you've written your very first
serviceworker so real quick if you liked
this video I hope that you head over to
serviceworker book.com and sign up for
my mailing list this book is gonna be
out really really soon and it's gonna
teach you this and then so much more
everything that you needed to know about
service workers and more you'll learn
how to take your app offline and make it
work so that your users have that really
nice really consistent experience if you
liked this please head over to
serviceworker book com sign up for the
mailing list you can follow me on
Twitter I am karma Lu thanks so much for
watching